all right ted cruz was asked about texas
seceding from the united states he was
like no i don't think we're there yet
but i get the sentiment i get why people
want to
why because if we succeed texas y'all
ain't going nowhere shut the [ __ ] up if
he goes if we succeed we take nasa we
take the military we take all the oil
yeah and people are going crazy and then
here's the best part before you say that
let me say yeah they said all right who
would be president and he said
joe rogan
he might be the president of texas let
me tell y'all something right now i mean
sincerely texas cut that [ __ ] out
y'all not allowed to go nowhere
so sit the [ __ ] down and shut the [ __ ]
up
talk about seceding from the great union
what happened last time part of the
country want to secede crack crack
backs got cracked total war tecumseh
sherman we will come light that whole
thing up have the whole [ __ ] state
looking like austin
if texas even dare secede from the union
we'll make the whole state austin that's
what we'll do we'll send the squad down
there the squad will run [ __ ]
literally the squad the squad yeah leoc
aoc yeah the muslims ilhan omar
aoc and the muslims yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah it is aoc in the muslim sounds like
a good band actually say what it sounds
like a nice band yeah yeah you'll see it
that same song
[Music]
[Laughter]
i don't think we could beat the whole
union but stay for state we'd [ __ ] up
every stage
don't let us call in some loans we're
the bank of bravos out here in this
[ __ ] don't let china call us alone
[Applause]
okay we just want to play it we just
won't pay him what you gonna do not pay
him what happened last time someone
tried to secede
that was different what happened that
was difficult i can't have nothing no
more no no i'm gonna take your flag
we're gonna take everything i'm not even
called texas but you could call it i'll
take texas back you'll call it you think
joe rogan
new york see last time it's called newer
york the newest york yeah there it is
last time he had robert lee he wasn't as
good as grant now we got rogan bro rogan
ready for war at all times
with us son wrote a name with you dawg
you think rogan wants to secede i don't
see a texas flag in this studio i see an
american flag that's what i'm trying
that's secession [ __ ] cut that [ __ ] out
keep it out your [ __ ] mouth i don't
want to hear it if i hear it again it's
going to be a problem text rogan see if
you want to be president of texas right
now i'm gonna i'm gonna i'm gonna text
him right now see if you wanna be
president of texas
i'm gonna text who said he's gonna be
president ted cruz ted cruz i don't even
want to defend ted cruz yo no
that's what i think ted cruz is trying
to get in with rogan
okay in the podcast
he also got into beef with big bird
ted cruz over what big bird got
vaccinated yeah yeah wait is ted an
anti-vaxx there's a very funny exchange
from a big bird
verified saying he got the vaccine and
then oscar the grouch the verified from
them being like i don't know man i don't
trust these vaccines i've been doing a
lot of reading i think they're using
them to make us gay it's a really funny
exchange
maybe it's photoshop but somebody
attempted to send me yeah this is nice
fan there's no way i hope it's not why
can't it not be can i live in this world
you can but oscar the grouch is
hilarious ted cruz actually did respond
and said yo this is propaganda stop
trying to tell [ __ ] dumbass stop trying
to get her
[ __ ] [ __ ] would you
even figure that out big bird got
vaccinated for real yeah stupid [ __ ]
olivia rodrigo doing propaganda at least
this one i trust yo thank god we got
this vaccine for for uh
people to complain about bro
what would they complain about if we
didn't have this whole vaccine nothing
to talk about like literally what would
they complain about what do you think
they would what issue do you think that
they would make up
you talk about masks or something talk
about trump for a while mass and
vaccines it's done let's say there's no
mass or vaccines
good what is he is a critical race
theory critical race theory actually
thank god we have the vaccine i don't
want to [ __ ] deal with that critical
race yeah that's good that thing is too
smart for people
like just hearing critical most people
go i learned about that yeah yeah i mean
like if it was called anything else yeah
if it was called like learn about
whiteness like i think people would
actually get into it but critical race
theory is just too
sophisticated it's not worth the time i
tried reading about it i was like yeah i
didn't have to make it this exactly just
dumb that [ __ ] down you know exactly i
refuse to learn what it is
you read it and you could have done this
simpler yeah do you want to tell me
something the language is mad flowery
yeah [ __ ] is mad flowery bruh yeah i
don't want to hear it yeah flower it i
don't want that's what critical race
theory is what the rest of america
thinks when we hear texas wants us to
see
that's what we think we're like what
also puerto rico you're never going to
be a steak why not why not [ __ ] the flag
up son of symmetry you better go and get
nine more but we could lose one steak go
get nine more steps
the dakotas no
we need two decoders no we don't i don't
think we need one to be honest with you
no we need two dakotas wait why because
they were there
protecting us from the canadian show
coming up yeah
100 we needed two to go this yeah
in the south in south dakota i don't
know which [ __ ] one what if we give
her to oregon fargo north dakota yeah
you ain't doing south dakota rushmore's
in south dakota make that dakota bro
i'm okay with that yeah
what about virginia
people better be going i'm mostly on
your side i used to kind of do a joke
about that
have one too yeah
[ __ ] i just want to disagree with you
but uh
i thought it would create more tension
and more fun but um but yeah but no no i
it needs to be even i care about how the
flag looks
so if they do it they do have to
remember yeah we consolidate it we get
rid of west virginia put that that's a
suburb yeah let's go oh yeah
it's a lot we don't yeah i think it's
just too much work for puerto rico to
become a state yeah like getting rid of
a state would be too much like all those
jobs and the senators and [ __ ]
whatever is what are they called house
representative everybody be bitching and
[ __ ]
so i don't know if we'd be able to make
it happen but yeah puerto rico no chance
all right that's fair yeah
you